hopefully we all remember our good
friend the chain rule from integral
sorry from differential calculus that
tells us if i were to take the
derivative with respect to x of
g of f of x
g uh let me write those parentheses a
little bit closer
g
of f of x
g of f of x that this is just going to
be equal to
the derivative of g with respect to f of
x so we could write that as g prime of f
x
g prime
of
f of x times the derivative of f with
respect to x
times
f prime of x and if you want to see it
in the in in the other notation i guess
you could say it would be
you could write this part right over
here as the derivative of g with respect
to f
times the derivative of f the derivative
of f with respect to x and then that's
going to give you the derivative of g
with respect to x this is just a review
this is the chain rule that you remember
from or hopefully remember from
differential calculus it's hard to get
it's hard to get too far in calculus
without really groking really
understanding the chain rule so what i
want to do here is well if this is true
then can't we go the other way around if
i wanted to take the integral of this if
i wanted to take the integral of
g prime
of f of x
g prime of f of x times f prime of x
dx
well this should just be equal to
this should just be equal to g of f of x
g of f of x and of course whenever i'm
taking an indefinite integral
g let me make sure the same color g of
f of x so i just swap sides i'm going
the other way so if i'm taking the
indefinite integral wouldn't it just be
equal to this and of course i can't
forget that i could have a constant here
now that might have been introduced
introduced because if i take the
derivative the constant disappears
and so this idea you could really just
call the reverse chain rule
reverse
reverse
chain
the reverse chain rule which is
essentially or it's exactly what we did
with u-substitution we just did it a
little bit more methodically with
u-substitution and we'll see that in a
second but before we see how u
substitution relates to what i just
wrote down here let's actually apply it
and see where it's useful and this is
really a way of doing u-substitution
without having to do u substitution or
doing u substitution in your head or
doing u substitution like problems a
little bit faster so let me give you an
example
so let's say that we had and i'm going
to color code it so it jumps out at you
a little bit more
let's say that we had
sine of x and i'm going to write it this
way i could write it
so let's say
sine of x
sine of x squared
and obviously the typical convention the
typical
the sine of x squared the typical
convention would be to put the squared
right over here but i'm going to write
it like this and i think you might be
able to guess why sine of x squared
times cosine of x
times actually i'll do this in a let me
just in a different color times cosine
of x
times
cosine of x so i encourage you to pause
this video and think about does it meet
this pattern here and if so what is this
indefinite integral going to be
let's think about it
if f of x is sine of x what's the
derivative of that what's f prime of x
well f prime of x in that circumstance
is going to be cosine of x
and what is g
well g is whatever you input into g
squared
so what's this going to be if we just do
the reverse chain rule
well this is going to be
well we take oh sorry g prime is taking
whatever this thing is squared so g is
going to be the antiderivative of that
so it's going to be taking something to
the third power and dividing and then
dividing it by three so let's do that so
the if we essentially take the
anti-derivative here with respect to
sine of x instead of with respect to x
you're going to get
you're going to get
sine of x
sine
of x
to the
to the third power over
three and then of course you have the
you have the plus
c
and if you don't believe this just take
the derivative of this you'll have to
employ the chain rule and you will get
exactly this and you say well what how
does this relate to u substitution well
a new substitution you would have set u
equals sine of x then d u would have
been cosine of x dx and actually let me
just do that that actually might clear
things up a little bit
you would set this to be u
and then this
all of this business right over here
would then be d u
and then you would have the integral
you would have the integral u squared
u
squared
i don't have to put parentheses around
it u squared
d u
u squared d u well let me do that in
that orange color u squared d u well
that's pretty straightforward this is
going to be equal to
u
this is going to be equal to u to the
third power
over three plus c which is equal to what
well we just said u is equal to sine of
x you reverse substitute and you're
going to get exactly that right over
here so when we talk about the reverse
chain rule it's essentially just doing u
substitution in our head so the next few
examples i will do exactly that